tant en tête d'un cortège qui fera le
tour de la ville
le premier magistrat de rivière pilote
accompagné de quelques élus
juste derrière la voiture qui transporte
la dépouille les parents soutenus par
des proches et de ce silence
assourdissant résident les et à krefeld
eu peu timide
[Musique]
à l'entrée de l'église comme pour
atténuer une atmosphère pesante amiez
anonymes tente de trouver condoléances
aux parents du petit garçon seigneur
nous sommes passés de la nuit parce que
mehdi s'est éloigné de nous c'est par
cette phrase lourde de sens que le père
moncontour qui a fait le trajet depuis
sa paroisse pour l'occasion donné le ton
de ses obsèques
ichiro et dans l'église où medi a été
baptisé deux ans plus tôt la joie
laisser place aux larmes
surtout quand le père cas taillé à coups
de passages bibliques tente à son tour
de répondre à une question que toute
l'assemblée se pose pourquoi pourquoi un
enfant de trois ans dans la fleur de
l'âge at il perdu la vie dans ce bus et
au fur et à mesure des mots des curés
qui se succèdent les visages murs fille
les larmes et le sentiment
d'incompréhension passe un petit
cercueil blanc
[Musique]